this one is actually a mold so it has
like a texture that oh yeah my favorite
is are the purple yellow okay we're
using bacteria as basically an agent to
paint with you can manipulate the DNA of
bacteria I want to use bacteria as a
detection agent for toxins in the
environment or for the detection of
cancer in a scientific world the focus
is actually on the applications of this
material idea relationship as an artists
are more interested in the philosophical
representational or even interpretation
level do they know what they're going
the visiting artist program really
became active in the 1970s but even
before that you really have to go back
to Jerry Kepesh who came over from the
Bauhaus he landed here and he said oh
I'm in a different environment this is
an environment full of scientists full
of engineers full of people who are
trying to invent new things I really
think the artists and the scientists
have a lot to say to one another he
understood how the arts could fit in at
an institution of em it's-- quality and
by the late 60s he had created the
center for advanced visual studies the
artists who were here were not satisfied
to just make art they wanted to develop
new technologies so it just came as a
kind of natural thing to create a
visiting artist program to enhance this
culture
the kinds of artists we wish to bring to
our campus our artists who have a feel
in the way they create the art that
intersects with science and technology
and to learn from us as we learn from
them if you could go into Fantasyland
and describe what would be the ideal
studio for any artist in the 21st
century you would be the MIT facilities
a lot of my work is trying to figure out
interesting ways to combine materials
with computers and through the research
and found out about Vic's work they sent
we can email immediately he responded
his I guess I want to come by I've heard
about MIT in the middle out for a long
time this is a highly abstracted image
because what's going on is that system
there is throwing charged particles of
gallium at the surface Vic has this
vision of etching castles into grains of
sand and he asked me that can we do this
at MIT is there a way that we can make
an image that's so small do can actually
put it onto a grain you've been going
through all these different kinds of
equipment creating really cool
techniques for a Qing it and then
imaging it as well
science can benefit enormously from
interacting with people were actually
concerned about how to represent the
physical world in a way that is
assessing what also understandable four
three two one zero and liftoff Trevor
paguen came to us with this project
where he wanted to put a plaque on a
satellite in a geostationary orbit
around the earth and very likely outlive
the planet how can we encode information
into the materials that can last for
very very long periods of time these
intersections between deep time and
human time are very interesting to think
about he decided to put a photographic
archive of major events in the life of
the Earthlings of this planet this is
not something I can do in my studio this
is not something I can do with materials
from my local art supply store this is
the kind of project that is really only
possible at a research institution like
MIT
what's really important about the
visiting artist program here is that
it's based on collaboration with our
existing creative arts faculty Joan
Jonas our performance artist in the
program in art culture and technology
was already collaborating with the young
jazz pianist Jason Moran a MacArthur
award winner brilliant pianist we
brought Jason here to MIT to work with
Joan to workshop a new performance piece
by Joe called reanimation phone and
volume added don byron is a brilliant
jazz composer guys really sound amazing
we brought him back to MIT where he
worked on a new piece for a gospel choir
and then he imposed a concerto for
clarinet for Evans a porrim which was
performed with the student wind ensemble
it's just a musical feast quite
literally they had quite a rapport the
two of them students need to learn how
to play things and rhythm and make them
feel good so i think i made the thing
rhythmically difficult on purpose
my name is Ravi lavage and I thought
that this morning would be may be
interesting to explain to you my method
of working putting students in contact
with people who are at the top of their
game whether it's in science or
engineering or the arts and having them
learn by creating alongside them is a
very special part of it might ease
educational philosophy no rules to this
you just draw the impressions that
McDermott award is one of the highest
level artist Awards in the world in all
cases the people who get the award spend
some time at MIT with the students in
some classes it's more than an honor
it's also an opportunity to benefit from
the creative culture here on campus any
questions any any doubts and fears when
you're starting out you're an amateur at
this you don't know what you're doing is
going to go off on the right direction
but then having someone who's done it
all their life and successful at it
coming to MIT and working with you and
making you feel like you're part of the
process let's to feel that you
definitely have a chance doing good work
but don't be nervous
da-da-da-da-da-da-da you know for the
young conductor the Los Angeles
Philharmonic was lavo Dudamel came here
to receive the award need an audience to
robert lepage the canadian theatre
maestro everything he does it all with
experience we've learned that we should
not force connections we let them and
eventually two three things seems to go
together and go there's a pattern there
I've never really seen the quote-unquote
division between the Arts and Sciences
as any kind of dichotomy to be a
complete person it makes sense to be
educated at both so having a vibrant
arts program at a school like mi tease
it is important for making complete
human beings for making human beings
that connect to the world asking
questions that haven't been asked before
when you put the artists into the mix I
think those questions become larger they
become more speculative and they also
have this human dimension this one is a
mistake it's not a actual experiment but
it still looks really cool working with
Vic has really made me think about the
whole cycle of technology and art and
how those two are interwoven and it's
just a beautiful cycle connecting nature
and the high technology that we practice
here it would be really interesting to
film on a microscope all the details
there there's a lot of intricate stuff
going on like some bacteria are swimming
in other bacteria are just climbing on
top of each other and they like to
communicate
you
you
you